well president biden is now facing
pressure to keep the national guard
away from the u.s southern border the
nation's
largest latino advocacy group it's
called lulac is urging the president to
stop states from sending
their own law enforcement troops to
tackle the border crisis saying quote
we told the president in no uncertain
terms this is an insurrection by
recalcitrant and rebellious states that
must
be stopped at least a dozen states have
deployed national guard troops to
confront
the surge of migrants critics though say
the biden administration
really left them no other choice listen
this administration from top to bottom
cannot pretend to be
serious about the crisis at the border
if they refuse to secure
our border and that means enforcing our
border policies
but that also means ending the magnet
policies
that are drawing people over here in the
first place it's clear the democrats are
not addressing anything but i'm really
glad to see that there are some
governors and some leaders
that are taking matters into their own
hands because they need to they need to
protect
and defend their states well mark
brnovich the attorney general of arizona
joins us now hi sir thanks so much for
taking time for us
this is now essentially pitting
president biden's
executive prerogative against state's
prerogative to protect their own
security interest
who do you see coming out on top here
ultimately
well thank you jillian for having me and
i think the first thing we always need
to start with is
what does the constitution say and the
reality is the states created the
federal government
governments sorry i said that sounds
like a reasonable place to start
oh thank you know yeah no i mean look
here at the end of the day the federal
government is charged with protecting
our borders they are not
the states have the right to have
militias we have the right to have
you know historically law enforcement
public health and safety was left to the
states
the bible administration has advocated
the responsibility they've incentivized
people coming here
we have record amount of people trying
to cross our border illegally
we know that there are 1.2 million
people deportation orders they are
refusing to deport including that means
criminals are being released into our
community
so the states are trying to do
everything they can but the reality is
is that this is the biden
administration's job
and one of the things that worries me so
much jillian about this letter in one of
our lawsuits against the bite
administration
emails had come out that during black
history month
activists had sent the white house
urging them emails and letters saying to
stop deportations
and they did so they're not listening to
ice they're not listening to law
enforcement
they're listening to activists and so i
think this is a bad sign
that the bible administration is going
to cave again to the far
left wing of the party and that's going
to result in people in the united states
getting hurt
so take a look at this a new poll now
shows that 33 percent of respondents
approve of president biden's handling of
the southern border
51 percent disapprove this is an issue
that has dog timid seems like
from day one i mean the vice president
has now traveled to the border region
she's traveled to the northern triangle
countries
have you seen any signs from anybody in
the administration
that the path forward may be clear that
things may improve
no i think if by any objective standard
whether you look at the numbers
whether you look at the spike in
fentanyl coming across our border
whether you look at
decrease in drug prices which means
there's more supply the bite
administration has empowered the cartels
they've made our communities more
dangerous by allowing criminals or those
charged with crimes
into our communities and it's only going
to get worse
look i don't care about the polls i
don't look at those what i do care about
is protecting hard-working
arizona and american taxpayers and i am
telling you there's going to be fiscal
costs associated with this
and there's going to be human tragedy
costs associated with it
whether that's the increase in overdose
deaths whether it's the increase of drug
dependency because what the cartels are
doing
or whether it's god forbid one of these
criminals being released hurting you or
one of your family members
the biden administration has advocated
their responsibility
so we've also learned here at fox news
that
the white house the attorney general
merrick garland are eyeing
the possibility of taking multiple other
states to court now over these new
election laws in addition to georgia it
could
likely include your state i want to
bring this up for viewers a letter in a
new letter to the doj you've promised to
fight any legal challenge
that you might receive you say arizona
will not sit back and let the binding
administration abuse its authority
refuse to uphold laws or attempt to
commandeer
our state's sovereignty um you know it's
a bold
promise there are you confident that
you're going to prevail
in a court of law yeah
vinnie vidivici i mean if you look at
the case i just argued with your supreme
court we won brnovich v dnc
it is clear the courts are not in the
mood for this nonsense
we know jillian if you look at the
hypocrisy of the left there are states
like new york connecticut new jersey
list goes on and on that have way more
restrictions when it comes to voting
than arizona does
we offer a plethora of options so if
indeed the biden administration
wants to take our state to court i will
fight them
and uh to quote al davis we will just
win baby
does the recent scotus ruling on arizona
kind of up the ante for you make the bar
higher
well i think it's going to make it much
more difficult for doj
to proceed with these publicity stunts
and let's make no mistake that's what
they
are the biden administration is trying
to appease the far left of the party
and what they are doing is shredding the
the role the department of justice has
traditionally had i worked at doj at one
point
and the idea that they're going to kind
of selectively go into red states and
file lawsuits
because they want to micromanage our
elections is really not only contrary to
the constitution
but it exposes how political this is
because we know
that there are a whole host of left-wing
states with way
more restrictions than a state like
arizona has so shame on the doj
shaman the biden administration for
caving to left-wing activists
all right we've got to leave it there um
attorney general brnovich thanks so much
for joining us today we appreciate it